Alright guys so here is the example number two for this strategy. So I'm looking at Euro GPP on 4 hour of course. And you can see we are making lor-lor-lor-high, lor-low, actually no lor-low high and then another lor-low. And the internal market structure been creating lor-low-low highs for quite some time now. So it is clear that the auto flow is bearish. I'm not going back here.
I'm just looking at the price here, okay?
And as you can see, we are making low lows.
Low lows, low highs, low lows, low highs.
Cool, so now what we do have is this autoblog, okay?
Of course, this is hindsight, but you're gonna notice these, okay?
So, this is the candle and prize goes back into our pure,
so let's drop down to 15 minute time from.
And you can see that just over here,
we have a shift in market structure,
but notice what happened.
The market structure shift did not happen
during kills on ours.
Okay, so the kills on ours are basically two till,
my god, seven,
right and then 730 for this specific strategy only okay to him till 7 that is your
London and then from 730 till 1130 is your New York session make sure you set
your time zone to New York so now we're gonna wait okay we are going to wait till
this high is taken out again because this is liquidy now. When you have a market
structure shift outside the kills on ours and the kills on ours start which
happens right here. You don't want to look for market structure shift here. You
want to wait for first price to take out this high over here and then you want to
look for a clean market structure shift and that happens right here and let me
show you how. We also took out this high here. Okay, so that is a clear shift.
Low low higher high high low higher high. And then we have a market structure shift
during kills on ours. Perfect. Now this right here are our consecutive
bearish candles. And also look at this breaker block. It is in alignment with the
auto block. And this consecutive bullish candles becomes your auto block. Right? So you're
going to take your entry here put your stop right above this high over here and you go for
one to two simple as that let's go and see how this plays out as you can see we got our entry
right here at 645 and you can see we hit our take profit if we held that would have been a
beautiful trade but we only go for one to two. So I hope you learned something from
this example. Remember if let's say that this candle did not take out the high
here and then you had a shift over here. That is a low probability
low probability market structure shift. I want this clean liquidity sweep and
And then displacement that gives us market structure shift.
Something like boom, boom, boom, okay?
This is prime.
You have a liquidity sweep, right?
And then you mark your structure shift.
And this leg has consecutive candles of the same color.
So if I was looking at here, I would love to see bullish candles.
Take out this liquidity and then a market structure shift and I take my entry from here, couple.
So I really really do hope that you learned something from the strategy and from this example.
I'll give you guys one more example.